in the previous video you saw a few
examples of how vectorization by using
built-in functions and by avoiding
explicit for loops allows you to speed
up your code significantly let's take a
look at few more examples the rule of
thumb to keep in mind is when you
programming your neural network so when
you're programming logistic regression
whenever possible avoid explicit for
loops and it's not always possible to
never use a for loop but when you can
use a built in function or find some
other way to compute whatever you need
it will often go faster than if you
haven't explicit for me let's look at
another example
if ever you want to compute a vector you
as the product of a matrix a and another
vector B then the definition of a matrix
multiply is that you know UI is equal to
sum of a j AI J VJ alright that's how
you define UI and so the non vectorized
implementation of this would be you know
to set u equals NP plus zeros would be n
by 1 and then you know 4i and so on for
J and so on right and UI plus equals you
know a IJ times VJ so now this has to
foldings looking over both I and J so
that's a non vectorized version the
vectorized implementation would be to
say u equals NP dot a comma V and diems
plantation on the right to vectorize
version now eliminates two different for
loops and it's going to be way faster
let's go through one more example let's
say you already have a vector V in
memory and you want to apply the
exponential operation on every element
of say this vector V so you confuse you
equals in a vector that's e to the B 1 e
to the V 2 and so on down to e to the
the end
so this would be a non vectorized
implementation right which is that first
you initialize you to a vector of zeros
and then you have a for loop that
computes the elements one at a time but
it turns out that Python numpy have many
built-in functions that allow you to
compute these vectors with just a single
call to a single function so what I
would do to implement this is import um
numpy s and p and then you just call you
equals and p dot e to the B and so
notice that whereas previously you have
that explicit for loop with just one
line of code here on this V is an input
vector use an output vector you've
gotten rid of the explicit for loop and
the implementation land rights will be
much faster than the one needing
explicit value inside the numpy library
as many other vector value function so
NP dot log of V will compute the element
wise log n peeves computes the absolute
value MP dot maximum confuse the element
wise maximum so you take the max of
every element of B what's zero these
last are two this takes the element wise
square of each element of V you know 1
over V takes the element wise inverse
and so on so whenever you attempted to
write a for loop take a look and see if
there's a way to call a non PI built-in
function to do it without that for loop
so let's take all of these learnings and
apply it to our logistic regression
gradient descent implementation and see
if we can at least get rid of one of the
two folders we had so here's our code
for computing the derivatives for
logistic regression and we had two for
loops one was this one up here and the
second one was this one right so in our
example we had N and
equals two but if you had more features
than just two features then you need to
have a full group of a DW 1 DW 2 DW 3
and so on so it's as if this as you have
for J equals 1 to NX you know DW j pw j
you know gues updated all right so we
like to eliminate this second volume
that's what we'll do on the slide so the
way we'll do so is that instead of
explicitly initializing DW 1 DW 2 and so
on two zeros we're going to get rid of
this and instead make DW a vector so
we're going to set D W equals M MP dot
zeros and let's make those a on and X by
1 dimensional vector then here instead
of this you know for group over the
individual components we just use this
vector valued operation DW plus equals x
I times DZ I and then finally instead of
this we will just have DW on device
equals M so now we've gone from having
two for loops to just one folder we
still have this one for loop that loops
over the individual training examples so
I hope this video gave you a sense of
vectorization and by getting rid of one
full loop your code will already run
faster but it turns out we could do even
better so the next video will talk about
how to decorate justic regression even
further and you see a pretty surprising
result that without using any full loops
without needing for loop over the
training examples you could write code
to process the entire training set so
pretty much all at the same time so
let's see that in the next video